اعلنت نقابه يونايتد العماليه في بريطانيا
ان المحادثات مع الوزراء اليوم لانهاء
اضرابات موظفيها هيئه الصحه الوطنيه لم
تكن جيده وقال امين عام النقابه ان تركيز
الحكومه على الانتاجيه بدلا من الاجور كان
بمثابه اهانه لاعضاء النقاب الذين اوضحوا
انهم يعملون باكثر من 18 ساعه في اليوم
وكانت الحكومه البريطانيه قد عقدت اجتماعا
مع قاده نقابيين يمثلون قطاعات التمريض
والاسعاف وثائق القطارات وذلك في محاوله
لانهاء اكبر موجه اضرابات في البلاد منذ
عقود وقال رئيس الوزراء ريشي سوناك الذي
يتعرض لضغوط متزايده لتحسين العروض الاجور
للموظفي الرعايه الصحيه قال ان الحكومه
مستعده لاجراء محادثات مع قاده النقابات
حول الاجور على الرغم من رفض رئيس الوزراء
السابق اعاده
رفضه سابقا اعاده فتح المحادثات
مجددا